how do you create a critical thinker I
think the first thing that you have to
do is is show them how to make decisions
I want our Learners to make all the
decisions for themselves and they have
to learn the consequence of those
decisions where they're going to sit
when they're going to eat when they're
going to drink what tools they're going
to use to help solve the problems is
that formula going to work there's a
guide in there guide is like a teacher
but under the socratic approach a guide
isn't teaching a guide is guiding and
those those subtle differences matter
and so instead of saying hey Tommy you
did two plus four wrong there should
always be a question Tommy is two plus
four five and that little difference
asks him to make then another decision
to look at his own question and be like
I think it is is it not so you're
conditioning the mind to learn how to
make lots of little decisions good
decisions